and this week it's 24 things you don't
know about Jared cushon would you like
to see them on the sure you would
I first met Milani when she was the
entertainment at my bar mitzvah I have
less body hair than a dolphin my family
owns 666 5th Avenue which we bought
because I worship Satan
remember my wife has sex she lets me
watch
now that I brought peace to the Middle
East going to focus on the view
I'm such an observant Jew I don't work
from sundown Friday until sundown the
following Friday I once dressed as a
woman in college but it was only to get
a place on a lifeboat
I'm the Orthodox Jew but Ivanka's the
one who insists on through a
sheet
when I was a boy I saw Rosemary's Baby
and realized I'm not alone and my SAT
score was a check for 2.5 million
dollars
[Applause]
you